the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we were doing velocities and
accelerations we came up with si
continue to remind us talking about
velocities and accelerations of a point
with respect to another point to which
we've attached make this point here to
which we've attached a reference frame X
prime Y prime Z prime and there's a
vector that goes between these two and a
vector that goes there so that we can
say R of B with respect to O my inertial
frame is R of a with respect to O plus R
of B with respect to a these are all
vectors and then from these we derive
velocities and acceleration formulas and
so we've come up with a couple of very
handy formulas the velocity formula
velocity of B with respect to O is the
velocity of a with respect to O plus you
have to take time derivative of this and
so I'm going to give you just the
general expression here just as a brief
reminder it's the derivative of B with
respect to a has seen in the a XYZ frame
plus Omega with respect to O cross RBA
these are all vectors so that's the ball
that's the velocity formula remember
this is the if you're in the frame
rotating and translating with it this is
the change of length of the vector and
this then is the contribution to the
velocity that you see in the fixed frame
that comes from the rotation and we then
got into polar coordinates and we found
out that if you use polar coordinates
then you can express this as the
velocity of a with respect to O plus r
dot R hat and I should really say
cylindrical coordinates z dot
k hat plus r theta dot theta hat so
that's exactly the same thing this is
full 3d vector notation this is a
special case of a coordinate system
which we call Koller coordinates and we
have came up with another formula for
accelerations the full 3d vector version
of that a with respect to O plus this is
the acceleration of B with respect to a
but as seen in the a XYZ frame to Omega
cross and this is the velocity as seen
in the XYZ frame so these things this is
no contribution from acceleration this
is no contribution from acceleration
plus Omega dot cross R b/a plus Omega
cross Omega cross R b/a
all vectors this is a movement of the
frame the acceleration of it with
respect to this is pure translation this
is the acceleration of the dog on the
merry-go-round with respect to the
center of the coordinate system there
does not involve rotation this is this
term that we call Coriolis this is a
term we call Euler this is the angular
speed up of the system angular
acceleration and this is centripetal
and if you do these if you want to go to
cylindrical coordinates and what we're
going to do next is just do some
applications here the acceleration of B
with respect to O and cylindrical
coordinates translation piece plus a now
in cylindrical it's useful to group
these so I'm going to put together this
term and this term because they're both
in the R hat direction and I'm going to
put together these two terms because
they're both in the theta hat direction
and I need is e zwk because it's
cylindrical and then I have the theta
hat piece R theta double dot plus 2 r
dot theta dot theta hat that's this is
the same thing as this except this is
expressed in cylindrical coordinates in
cylindrical coordinates are particularly
good for doing the kind of problems that
are mostly done at the level of this
course which we call planar motion
problems confined to an XY plane and
confined to single axis rotation in the
Z which is this is a high coordinate
system it's ideally suited to do
problems like that and that's why we use
it so now let's do let's do some
examples and this gets into this is
really quite a powerful now that you
have these two equations you can do a
lot of kinematics and dynamics
so we started last time right at the
very end I said okay let's do this
problem really quickly right constant
rotation rate constant radius no angular
acceleration no change in length of the
thing pretty simple problem and we
exhibit it off really fast and I wanted
to start there do that really quickly so
this is my case one it's my ball on the
string here's point a here's point B
here's the theta hat direction R hat
direction okay and it has some constant
length R here so r dot R double dot R
zero
there's no also Z C dot Z double dot
we're just no Z motion at all those are
all 0 theta dot is a constant I'll call
it cap Omega in the K hat direction
right hand rule theta double dot zero so
with the way the easy way to use these
formulas is you just started knocking
out all the terms that you don't need so
but let's just to give you a little
quick review of how to use these things
let's use the vector full 3d version of
velocity equation for a second the full
3d version says the velocity of air is
respect to O what's that in this problem
that's not the translating term so I was
standing still not going anywhere but if
we're walking along I'd still spend that
thing ok so this problem this term is
zero this problem r dot
let's go here what's this is the rate of
change of the length of the string in
the coordinate system of the string
walking along so what's our dot okay so
that terms 0 and Omega cross R b/a
well R is in the our hat capital r r hat
cross with omega a k right k cross r is
k cross our hat theta hat so we get our
familiar this first term is 0 the second
term is 0 the third term we just get our
R Omega in the theta hat direction we
know that to be true the point I'm just
trying to make here is you can always
just fall back and use the vector
formula full 3d vector formulas of both
just plug it in and everything will just
drop out you can also then go to these
simply to the cylindrical coordinate
terms when you happen to have it all
expressed in those in coordinates of
that kind of make it simpler for you
okay so now let's quickly then do the
acceleration of B with respect to O and
let's use the formulation already in
cylindrical coordinates what's a with
respect to 0
what's our double dot how about the r
theta dot squared term 0 or not nope
let's go on z double dot r theta double
dot r dot theta dot okay we only end up
with one term actually i'm going to keep
this one for a second able to respect oh
- and we came up with our r theta dot
squared R hat term I leave this in here
because I actually don't don't have to
say if I were if I want it now to do
this problem if I ask you to do a
problem where I'm doing this and I start
accelerating do you know how to do it
there's answers still there right
all right
what's let's do a quick free body
diagram here's our mass my master
coordinate system out here let's draw
let's say it's you know right here at 90
degrees what are the external forces on
the mass in this problem so there's
tension in the string right okay so now
this is a really trivially simple
problem so the point of the emphasis I'm
here is on the concept so now when
you're asked to come up with an equation
of motion or compute the forces on a
mass Newton use Newton's second law F
equals mass times acceleration you now
have the complete 3d vector formulation
for acceleration of a syst particle you
know translating rotating coordinate
system that's all you need to compute
accelerations for lots and lots of
difficult problems and so if you can
write down the acceleration you say it's
equal to what mask'd if you've
multiplied mass times that acceleration
what's that equal to the forces that
must be acting on the system and that's
the point here so now I want to know the
forces on the system the summation of
the external forces and then these are
vectors and you can do them component by
component the sum of the external forces
in the R hat direction must be equal to
the mass in this case just a particle
times the acceleration of that particle
and in this problem then that would be
the mass times acceleration of a with
respect to O minus R theta dot squared R
hat
and this would have to be the are comp
they are hat component of this thing
right I've said I just want the are
component I'd have to figure out if I
was running along if I had a in the same
direction as our hat what part of that
accelerations in that direction that
would come here if there's zero is make
it zero so let's just say no let's just
let the acceleration of a with respect
to O be zero then that says the sum of
the forces in the r direction is equal
to the mass minus m r theta dot squared
and if we were to draw a Freebody
diagram we would find out that ah there
must be a tension on the string pulling
it on the mass sufficient to give it the
acceleration that you've computed so
every problem when you're asked to
compute the force or the next step up
find the equation of motion the equation
of motion is just spin it it's just you
know writing this thing out okay the now
okay I want to move on to a more
interesting problem
all right I'm going to do I want to do
this problem so it's a hollow tube and
we're going to look at things like what
happened put a ping-pong ball in it okay
and if I swing this tube around ping
pong ball is going to come out right
okay there must be some forces on that
thing to cause it to come out there must
be some accelerations on that thing so
if I could conceivably have an R a theta
double dot acceleration it certainly is
going to have theta dot rotation rates
the balls allowed to move there can be
non zero R dots are double dots a lot
going on inside of this simple little -
all right so let's that's what I want to
figure out let's see if we can come up
with a model for this problem
so here's my z-axis I have a rotation
around it some theta dot k hat direction
here's my tube it's rotating around so
this is sort of a side view your view of
the tube here's a ping-pong ball in
there and I'm going to I'm going to
idealize that ping-pong ball as a for a
minute a little more general problem I
have got let's say I have kind of a nut
on this thing a disc something on the
outs hanging on to the outside and I can
control the rate at which the speed at
which this thing goes out ping-pong ball
that's just that's a this is going to be
an application of this but I want to be
able to do several other versions like
can like make the speed constant for a
second okay and looking down on this
thing
top view here's our initial frame maybe
out here like this here's my mass so in
polar coordinates here is your theta the
R is this this is your R hat this is
your theta hat directions okay I'm going
to let the velocity of a with respect to
O be zero so there's no translation of
this system and z z dot z double dot
those are all zero nothing's happening
in the z direction so I want to first
compute the velocity of B with respect
to O and you got to be able to do that
sort of by inspection right it comes
only from oh I haven't told you now what
do I want to hope make happen in this
problem I want to let
our dot it's going to be some VR and
it's constant I'm not going to go quite
to my ping pong shooter here yet I'm
going to do a slightly simpler problem
first so this is a constant that means
our double dot is zero so this thing is
just like let's say you had threads on
this thing and it's a screw and it's
just moving its way out at a constant
rate and I'm going to have constant
angular so theta dot and I'll call that
cap Omega K so the angular rate is also
constant all right if that's the case
can you tell me so what to be with V of
B with respect to my fixed frame oh well
any time you're not sure you go back to
this formula throw out terms and no Z
dot term this is constant this is zero
zero zero you have this term some VR and
the R hat direction you have this term
right wherever it happens to be in the
theta hat direction okay
our dot R hat Direction plus R theta dot
in the theta hat direction
okay we need acceleration next V with
respect to O and now you crank through
the terms again this time first term is
zero second term is zero because it's
constant third term is definitely not
zero four three zero fifth term zero
this term not zero so let me just write
them so you get a minus R theta dot
squared R hat and that's the radial
Direction term plus 2 r dot theta dot
theta ad that's the accelerations so you
have an acceleration now in the R hat
direction and in the theta hat direction
if there's acceleration to those
directions there must be forces F equals
Newton's second law now says you know
again the force is the mass times the
acceleration and this is a vector this
is a vector it has two components and
the nice thing about these Newton's laws
and vectors you can break the problems
down into their vector components and
treat the our direction as one equation
of motion in the theta direction as a
separate one
so we might want to draw a Freebody
diagram here's this block working its
way out we know that there's probably
some axial force I'm just going to call
it t and there's some other unknown
force here in the theta hat direction so
this is my theta hat I've drawn this
just intentionally in the positive R hat
direction the sign that it comes out
will tell us which direction it really
is if you if you're not certain just
draw it positive in the positive R hat
direction and this is the that's your
free body diagram if I wanted to put
gravity in there
I might have but
we're doing this in the horizontal plane
we'll call gravity is in and out this
way it's in the Z direction and we know
it's constrained can't move Z double dot
zero so there's probably some there's
certainly a support force that picks up
the weight but this is in our horizontal
plane
there's your Freebody diagram and we can
write two equations to solve for these
things so some some of the forces in the
R hat direction is T and that must be
equal to the mass times the acceleration
in the R - M R theta dot squared in the
R hat direction
sure enough the tension has to go has to
pull inwards in the minus our hat
direction and that's the fold result
where are they okay so if this and bring
the ball to the outside where you can
see it this thing is going in this
direction right horizontal plane XY
plane it's moving it's fixed rate out
all right so it's speed when it's in
here is our over to Omega in that
direction when a speed wind is out here
it's our Omega in that direction so
clearly it's it's picking up speed right
if it's picking up speed is the picking
up kinetic energy is their work being
done on it somehow to build up that
energy so there must be some forces at
play okay so there's a there's a normal
force from the wall of this thing
pushing this ball sideways to speed it
up for sure that's one force and the
other force is because I'm cannot
allowing this thing just to go freely
out I'm constraining it to constant
speed out it would really like to go a
lot faster than that so what's holding
it back it's at any instant of time it
has centripetal acceleration and what's
whole what's keep making it go in the
circle is a force that is in this case
if that were a nut with threads it
forces and the threads are applying to
the knot to keep it from getting from
running away
well I've broken down I've chosen I the
total force acting on this thing is some
combination of a force in that direction
and a combination in the axial direction
so it has some net net vector direction
that's neither this nor that right but
so this this thing is rotating about
some center over here right so this is
theta dot theta is going in this
direction theta dot and it's just we've
chosen a coordinate system that has unit
vectors R hat and theta hat and so it
makes sense we can express the
acceleration in terms of those two
components it makes sense to express the
forces in the same direction so I've
just arbitrarily said I have some
unknown force that's in this direction
and I have another unknown force in that
direction and but I know that that I'm
saying there account for all forces in
this direction whatever their source
that tells me that some of the external
forces in the theta hat direction in
this case is this unknown F but I know
from Newton that that's got to be equal
to the mass times acceleration in that
direction but in this case then that is
2m r dot theta dot theta hat okay so
there must that got this right district
way ssin and applying Newton's second
law I can find out what that force must
be then it would have been a lot more
work if I had drawn it in some arbitrary
in-between direction because then I'd
have to break it down into its
components to write this so I've done it
made it as easy as possible for myself
so there's a force like this and there
is another force like that this one week
is
was caused by the centripetal
acceleration or this force causes the
centripetal acceleration in order to
make something go in a circular path you
have to exert a force on it that's the
force and in order to accelerate
something angular ly you have to apply a
force that comes from the euler term and
this is the curious term this is the
Coriolis term and that's so where does
it come from you know that's the it's a
that's that's the crux of the matter
here where does it come from so part of
the reading that you need to do now is
chapter 15 chapter 15 most of it is
going to be to complete review it just
says the conservation of a linear
momentum impulse and momentum but it
also gets into angular momentum so we're
going to talk quite a lot about angular
momentum but and I want to do very brief
little review right now
that it so that it applies to this
problem so we've come up with an
expression that the force in the theta
Direction here comes there's got to be
that 2m r dot theta dot so here's my
point O and a for that matter but
looking down on our problem here's my
mass some instant in time my rotation
rate is theta dot work actually colic
it's constant so it's K hat like that
Kappa Omega K hat this is my R hat
direction theta hat now this is I'm
going to treat this as a particle not
long we're going to be talking about the
dynamics of rigid bodies we're just
doing particles for the moment we think
of them just as point masses and don't
deal with their with their finite extent
so we're still thinking of this as a
particle and I'm going to write down the
definition of the angular momentum of a
particle this is be out here with
respect to my fixed frame here at O and
I'm going to use a lowercase H to
describe angular momentum of particles
that I'll be using to use capital H to
describe the angular momentum of rigid
bodies so this is a particle definition
of the angular momentum of a particle
with respect to a fixed point what we're
going to come back to that that'll turn
out to have some significance the
definition of this is it's our B oh the
position vector cross with the linear
momentum evaluated in the fixed frame so
that's the definition of angular
momentum which is you have linear
momentum and it's the cross product with
the position vector out to it so in this
case the rbo is
Capital are our hat this is well it's
not it's not this various excuses I'm
not going to use it better or not I
don't want to this I use as a constant I
better keep it as the variable pardon
that so it's our whatever the local
position is in the R hat direction
crossed with the linear momentum
what's the linear momentum of that
particle mass times velocity what's the
velocity theta dot where do we write it
up here someplace
are the total velocity is r dot R hat
plus R theta dot theta hat right and we
need a mass in here so mass times
velocity would be the momentum and we
need the cross products without our hat
cross our hat you get nothing from that
and our hat cross theta hat positive or
negative positive K right so this
becomes M R squared theta dot in the K
hat direction
and this is this one is a constant
alright this is cap Omega okay so this
is my angular momentum of my particle
with respect to this fixed reference
frame and so last one final step that
you know from your previous physics is
well house torque related to angular
momentum take again what do you remember
time derivative so D by DT of HBO here
the time rate of change of this vector
is the torque with respect to this point
with respect to O so what are constants
in this thing we don't have to deal with
their derivatives K hat is it does the
direction of the angular momentum change
it's upwards the derivative of K the
unit vector K does it change in this
problem no so there's no time for it to
zero it's times derivative is zero the M
time derivative is zero the only thing
you have to take derivative is r so to
our r dot
so the torque is 2m r r dot Kappa Omega
and it's all in the K direction and that
had better be our vo cross F torque
comes as a force times the moment arm
right and we computed here a force in
the theta direction so what would give
us a torque in the K direction at R
cross theta R hat cross theta hat gives
you a K right R cross and this force the
part of the force we have two forces one
in the r direction and one in the theta
direction the cross product this term up
here the t gives you nothing right
across our hat across our hat so the
only force that matters here is this
Coriolis one okay and so that force is
2m r dot theta dot and we have the R
cross we know this comes out in the K
direction and we get an R in here when
we compute this product and this to me
looks an awful lot like this except I
missed an R squared how do I do that
oh no it's not our squared it started
off over here as the angular momentum
has in our square it took the derivative
it dropped down to two our our dot
that's right
so the Coriolis force what's it got to
do with the angular momentum that's kind
of the point of the exercise here in
order for this ping-pong ball to excel
to be accelerated it's as it goes slowly
out this tube the angular momentum is
increasing in order to change angular
momentum with time you have to apply a
torque the torque that you have to apply
is 2m RR dot in the K direction and that
is our cross the Coriolis force so the
Coriolis force in this case is the force
that's necessary to increase the angular
one of the angular momentum system
that's very often the reason that's
where it what Coriolis force is about so
when you shoot an artillery piece in on
the earth
you got the projectile going out there
it has angular momentum with respect to
the earth and you'll find out that this
little term pops up and in fact the
projectile doesn't go straight it curves
there's lots of things that because of
conservation of angular momentum you end
up with this term popping up in this
case angular momentum is not conserved
it's increasing so you have this force
to make it happen any questions about
this we're going to see a lot you're
going to use this one a lot you going to
work with it a lot
so anytime you see changes in angular
momentum happening in a problem in these
moat in these problems with circular
motion velocities of parts increasing
and radius you'll almost always see this
term pop up anytime you see these
changes in angular momentum you'll often
see the Coriolis term
all right now we're going to do a let's
do a really another interesting problem
simple but interesting and that is
really to go let's go do this problem
where the things really allowed to come
freely out okay all right
you're ready to fend yourselves
all right a little short stick is pretty
effective at throwing candy all right
you got your safety glasses on you want
me to see if I can get one up there also
I obviously haven't practiced this right
all right
last one actually this just two more all
right what makes this work all right
let's do that let's do this problem
sorry let's look at our candy shooter
so I'm whipping this thing around
candies coming out of here is it B again
I got a nosy not mess with the Z part z
part is trivial to usually deal with
because it's totally independent just
separate equations doesn't complicate
things much at all even when you have Z
now in this case the velocity and here's
my old frame here the velocity of B with
respect to O well now it's got boss I'm
not going to move I'm standing still
when I do it so the first term is zero
it's got an R term r dot in the R hat
direction and it has an R theta dot
theta hat term okay and these can now
this might be changing this might have a
time derivative our double dot certainly
does it's accelerating coming out of
that tube and my theta angular motion it
can be accelerating too so we're gonna
have to deal with those I need to know
the accelerations now having to
emphasize it but it till now but it I
find it conceptually useful too and when
you work with polar coordinates you have
this you can it you can have this
ability to aggregate the terms in these
two component directions so this you
have this ball that our terms go
together and we've left the Z double dot
term it's just separate by itself drops
out easily and you have the theta hat
term and that's the R
theta double dot plus 2 r dot theta dot
and these are in the theta hat direction
there's your Coriolis term your Euler
acceleration term centripetal term yeah
well I don't know if I ought to tell you
secrets about me because it's going to
give you an advantage on the quiz but I
have almost never ever been known to ask
a question that says derive ok but I'll
sure ask you concept questions I really
want you understand the principles I
really need I'm not I don't get real
hung up on a have you need a grungy
grind-it-out
things do I want you to remember the
formula for how to take the derivative
of a vector in rotating frame yeah
that's what that that's where these have
come from
you had better remember this these two
formulas the velocity formula and this
and the acceleration format are just
core to this course now the way quizzes
are done first quiz you come in with one
sheet of paper what would it better be
on your paper ok and second quiz two
sheets final three sheets that kind of
thing ok conceptually you got forces in
the armed forces in the Z forces in
accelerations in R theta R theta and Z
forces R theta and Z so here's here's
here's the and for these planar motion
problems this one's sure easy to use so
let's think about this problem I'm going
to let this be frictionless just to make
it easy all right
so what possible forces act on the
punkah candy let's do a free body
diagram of the chunk of candy coming out
of here what are the forces in the let's
keep it planar you know we can get
gravity into this but I'm just let's
just do it in a plane so I'm just going
horizontal and slinging this thing
gravity is in the Z 2
direction and I'm constrained it in the
Z so not there must it's somebody
something supporting the gravity and the
tube so definitely there's an mg on this
thing downwards but it's in the Z
direction and we're just not we're not
letting it move in the Z what about the
horizontal distance R this is my R hat
direction this is my theta hat direction
whoops not either theta is going this
way so I've drawn this as a side view
what's the force in the R hat direction
okay in order to do this problem you got
to figure that out what are the forces
what are the source of forces in the r
direction
here's your R direction say what mind
you guys let me be yeah there are not
any is that what you said aren't any and
why is that right so there's no forces
in the r direction so there's no forces
on this thing in the r and if we this is
so then this is a side view we could do
the top view looking down top view you
got your XY you also have your here's
the thing here's the ball here's the r
hat here's the theta hat now Freebody
diagram in the top view well there's
some force here probably
ah absolutely she's commenting that we
do have accelerations in the R hat
direction right and no force so you're
getting that's the conundrum of this
problem that's the point of this problem
so let me continue ok Freebody diagram
so I'm allowing and looking down on it
I'm lying for some force it's a normal
force that comes from the pipe exerting
the force on the candy and it since it's
frictionless it can only be normal to
the pipe ok so there's there's the free
body diagram in the top view so we can
write two equations we can write three
equations this one equal to zero this
one in the R hat direction this one in
the theta hat direction
some of the forces our hat direction
must be zero and we have a mass we have
an acceleration solve for R double dot
remarkable there's no force in the R hat
direction the the position of the object
the R coordinate it has a velocity it
has an acceleration but the total
acceleration in the R hat Direction is
actually zero the rate of change of the
of the velocity of this thing in the
radial direction R double dot is non
zero but there are no forces on it I
have pondered another way to explain
this I'm still thinking about it
and you think about this too how do you
know how do you explain this in the
absence of forces and it's kind of is
partly where the concept comes from of
fictitious forces that centrifugal force
is a force it's not it's an acceleration
this is just saying that let's go back
to this problem in order to make
something go in a circle you have you
have to put a force on it to caused the
centripetal acceleration you have to
allow the thing to go out if you're not
forcing it to go in a circle you have to
allow it to go out at that rate in order
for there to be no sand trip Atal
accelerations on the object yeah
in the y-direction to get it started
does it experience and trip it'll
acceleration so there's no rotation does
it an experienced centripetal
acceleration what do you think yeah okay
it's because it goes through curved
motion at any instant time when it's
doing that there's a radius of curvature
you can at that instant time think of it
as being in a circular path okay and
sometimes it's just really easy to do
these kind of problems with normal and
tangential coordinates so if I wanted
I've got a I'm looking down on the XY
plane
gravity's into the earth so I'm looking
down on a vehicle a car and that car
guys kind of drunk he's going down the
road like this okay so here's my Y
here's my x and y equals some well a
sine 2pi over the wavelength two PI over
lambda times X and some a sine K X and
as you drive down that I'm interview if
you're in a car and you're doing that
you get thrown side-to-side in the car
right so you are being accelerated and
so we want to be able to calculate the
acceleration due to the fact that you're
going down and doing a curved path and
as we deal with these things with a
sometimes with a convenient little set
of coordinates that are our normal and
tangential unit vectors you normal and
you tangential at any instant in time
and we know that in the so this is if
this is along the path at any instant in
time you're right here what direction is
your velocity just definition of
velocity tangent to the path right okay
so a it's a time the velocity has got to
be tangent to the path at that moment
okay so velocity has some the vector has
a magnitude and a unit vector u T here
alcoholic tangent dollar to it and the
acceleration of this thing is your time
derivative of this and that's going to
give you a V dot u t hat plus AV and now
you need a time derivative of this guy
but this is a unit length vector you can
plug it into that equation for the
derivative of a rotating vector and
calculate what this should be you could
also just draw it out now so I'll draw
this for you
how many do at a time I'll just be able
to finish this
here's my unit vector in the tangential
direction as I'm going around this curve
this is my tangential direction there at
that it there's some incident I have a
radius we call that row and in the
little time delta T I go through an
angle Delta Theta in delta T and this is
my UT vector here it changes by a little
bit that's the change in the UT unit
vector in this time delta T and it goes
perpendicular and it goes in the
positive u in direction so Delta the
easiest way to write this one Delta u T
equals some theta dot delta T that's the
angle times the times the length of the
unit vector 1 that's the distance it
goes so one so R Omega 1 theta dot is
the distance that this unit vector goes
through in delta T and the direction it
goes in is u normal hat so Delta u T
over delta T limit as T goes to zero you
get theta dot u and just like before so
the time derivative of this unit vector
in the tangential direction is just
stated dot time in the normal direction
and then from that we can
very quickly derive the rest of this
acceleration the acceleration that is
that Plus this we now know an expression
for this is my U T dot term and plug
that in here this then we need an
expression for V what's the V well if
that instant time it has some radius Rho
it has an angular velocity theta dot so
Rho theta dot would be the B here so I'm
looking for an expression for V u T dot
so that's V theta dot e UN but theta dot
is V over Rho V squared sorry about this
over Rho u n so this guy up here this is
V dot u T plus V squared I'll rewrite it
over Rho u n so if you're speeding up if
you're going from 30 miles an hour to 40
miles an hour
that's your tangential that's your P
speed along the path that's this term
but because you're going around the
curve you have an acceleration B squared
over Rho when you've run this into this
before in physics this is where it comes
from okay this is a centripetal
acceleration like term if you replace V
with Rho theta dot you'd get R theta dot
squared so you can either put it in
terms of V squared of a row or you can
put it into in terms of Rho theta dot
squared and Rho theta dot squared sounds
a lot like my acceleration term right
here okay
so with that simple little formula you
can do you need one other thing and you
need to and you just go look it up in
the book there is an expression from
calculus for the radius of curvature of
a path right and it has things it has
first and second derivatives of Y with
respect to X so you need a dy/dx and a
d2y DX squared from a sine function you
can calculate that so you calculate Rho
from this from the formula that's in the
book for calculating radius of curvature
and you're done all right so see you on
Thursday